foreign
YouTube channel today we are here with
an interesting video on the min max
algorithm in AI so without any further
delay let us have a look at the agenda
for today's session
first let us try to understand what is
min max algorithm in AI then let us know
the properties of the min max algorithm
and moving ahead let us go through the
pseudocode of the min max algorithm and
finally let us understand it's working
so if you want to become an expert in
the field of AI and machine learning
then take up the professional
certificate program in Ai and ml by
simply learn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description for more details
the Minimax algorithm is a popular
decision making algorithm in artificial
intelligence used in Game Theory and
decision Theory it is a backtracking
algorithm that uses the depth first
search concept to traversal all the
nodes of a tree and it writes out
different possibility in a systematic
Manner and backtracks when a solution is
not found the Minimax algorithm is
commonly used in two player games like
chess Checkers and tic-tac-toe the
algorithm's main goal is to choose the
best move for the player currently
making a move assuming that the opposing
player would also play optimally
minimizing the player's maximum possible
loss advancing let's have a look at some
of the properties of the min max
algorithm
first we have completeness the min max
algorithm will find a solution if it
exists in the given find it game trade
next optimal the algorithm is optimal if
both players makes an optimal move
then time complexity the time complexity
of the min max algorithm is order of B
to the power of M as it performs a depth
first search of the game tree where B is
the game tree's branching factor and M
is the trace maximum depth and then we
have space complexity the space
complexity of the min max algorithm is
the same as the depth first search order
of B into M as it follows the same
principle next we will move on to the
pseudo code for the min max algorithm
let's try to understand the pseudocode
of the min max algorithm so here the
function min max except three arguments
that is node depth and max player so
note the current game State and depth
the maximum depth of the search tree and
the max player a Boolean variable that
indicates whether the current player is
trying to maximize or minimize their
score so first the function checks if
the current node is terminal or if the
maximum search depth has been reached so
if either condition is true the function
returns a heuristic node value next
suppose the current player is the max
player so in that case the function is
initializes the best value to negative
Infinity recursively calling the min max
function
it evaluates each child of the current
node with Max values set to false here
we have the max value that is set to
false and then the best value is updated
at the maximum of the current best value
and the value written by the recursive
call and then finally the function will
return the best value else if
the current layer is the mean player the
function initializes the best value to
positive infinity and by recursively
calling the Minimax a function evaluates
each child of the current node with the
maths player set to true so here we have
the max player set to true and the best
value is updated as a minimum of the
current best value and the value written
by the recursive call and then finally
the function will return the best value
next let's move on to the working of the
min max algorithm
min max refers to the algorithm strategy
of minimizing the maximum possible loss
so the Minimax algorithm works by
constructing a tray of all possible
moves and their outcomes starting from
the current game state
a game tree is a graphical
representation of the different moves
that players in a game can make as well
as the results of those moves it is a
game tree that starts at the root note
and branches out into different notes
reflecting different possible moves in
game theory and artificial intelligence
game trees are often used to analyze and
solve games they can be used to
determine the best move for a player
given a specific game state or to
compute the predicted outcome of a game
depending on the each player's move so
let's consider this example where we
have two players Max and Min and we also
have the terminal nodes so let's
consider a to be the initial state of
the game tree so if max player takes the
first move then according to the pseudo
code to the maximizer it is the best
value is equal to negative infinity and
for minimizer it is the best value is
equal to positive Infinity so we now
find the utility value or score for the
maximizer the maximizer will compare
each value of the terminal node with its
initial value which is negative infinity
and choose the maximum value among all
we have 4 or N2 so it will check the
maximum value so in 4 and 2 it will
choose the value 4 and then in minus 3
and minus 6 the max player will choose
minus 3 because minus 3 is the max value
compared to -6
and then it will check in 7 and 0 so it
will compare and it will choose the
value 7 then 5 and 8 it will choose 8.
the next move is of minimizer so it will
start comparing all the nodes value with
positive Infinity so basically it will
choose the values that are minimum and
it will choose the values or score for
the third layer so it will start
comparing 4 and minus 3 so since minus 3
is the minimum value it will choose the
minus 3 and then in 7 and 8 it will
choose 7 because it is a minimum and
then again the next turn is of maximizer
it will choose the maximum value from
the node for the root node so
here n minus 3 and 7 the maximum is 7 so
the maximizer will choose the maximum
value to the root node so this is the
complete working of the min max 2 player
game so we have just considered four
layer game tray but when you take only
two player games they will have many
layers in it so just for our
understanding we have considered this
example but in online two player games
we will have complex game tree and I
hope you got the idea of min max
algorithm
so guys I have a simple question for you
so looking at this game tree find out
what is the optimal value and let me
know in the comment section below so if
you like this video share with your
friends before I sign off make sure you
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to get all the updates we'll
be back with more such interesting
videos until then keep learning and stay
tuned to Simply love
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here